معنى الانا من عمان اللواء فايز الزويري
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي اهلا بك لواء
فايز دويري يعني تحدث عن هذه القنابل التي
تستخدمها روسيا لاول مره منذ بدء الحرب
على اوكرانيا هذه القنابل خارقه التدمير
على ماذا يؤشر هل هي هو تحول في
الاستراتيجيه ام على صعوبات ميدانيه وجهها
روسيا
انا اعتقد ان السبب الرئيسي هو طبيعه
الاهداف التي تم مهاجمتها عندما يتم تحديد
الاهداف التي تنوي اي جهه او اي جيش
مهاجمتها خاصه بسلاح الجو يتم تحديد انواع
الذخائر بناء على طبيعه الهدف هناك اهداف
محصنه تحتاج قنابل اعماق هناك ابراج تحتاج
قنابل فراغيه هناك مستودعات وقود تحتاج
قنابل حارقه اذا دعيني اقول طبيعه الهدف
هو الذي يحدد نوعيه السلاح الذي سيتم
استخدامه
القنبله الانزلاقيه باختلاف الاهداف كما
تقول على ماذا يؤشر ما الاهداف التي يمكن
ان نتوقعها الان من خلال اختلاف هذه
الذخائر اليها
يعني الان تم استهداف مناطق او مواقع
محصنه هذه المواقع المحصنه لو تم استخدام
قنابل ما يسمى الاسقاط الحر او الجنرال
وهذه قنابل احجامها متباينه لن تثدي الى
النفس الى نفس النتيجه خاصه اذا عدنا الى
الوراء عندما كنا الحديث عن سوليدار كان
هناك انفاق الملح وهذه تحت اعماق كبيره من
الارض اذا دعيني اقول طبيعه الاهداف الان
هذه القنبله
استخدمت اكثر من مره وقبل اسبوعين استخدمت
في تشيرنيهم وبالتالي اذا انا اقول طبيعه
الهدف هو الذي يحدد نوع السلاح اشكرك لواء
فايزه الدويري الخبيله العسكري
واستراتيجيه كنت